hey what is up guys I'm kid Bhd here and
I am in San Francisco California of
course for Google i/o 2014 and here I've
got my hands on the LG G watch so there
were 3 smartwatches shown off for the
first Android wear smartwatches at
Google i/o there was the Moto 360 the
circular one that everyone's talking
about then there was a Samsung one
called the Samsung gear live and then
there's the LG one which is called the
LG G watch the G watch is retailing for
$229 in the Google Play Store starting
today and from my hands on in my
impressions of it it's actually not all
that different from the Moto 360 aside
from the shape which I'll talk about in
a second so it's a 280 by 280 resolution
it comes in black or white it's the
stainless steel in terms of size
obviously I don't have the biggest risk
in the world but it's kind of similar in
size to a pebble steel I'd say a little
bit bigger
it obviously has bezel on the top on the
bottom but it's a square form factor and
it looks really similar to a pebble so
with a SmartWatch something a lot of
people are gonna wonder about is the
battery life and the standby time and
what LG told us is the standby time is
gonna be somewhere around 36 hours with
that 400 million power battery and for
the size you're getting it at it's
always on and that LCD screen is pretty
bright looking you're gonna get that
always on for 36 hours so it doesn't
seem all that bad
of course raising it up with your wrist
we'll get that screen to activate so it
gets a lot brighter and it'll show you
you notifications and basically when we
were using this watch it's in a retail
lonely mode so you're not gonna get to
actually use the voice commands or the
things that'll do when it's connected to
your smart phone you can think of this
as Google now and your Android
notification center on your wrist that's
basically all it does so it will give
you all your Google now notifications
how many steps you've taken the weather
and then your Notification Center so if
you have music playing you can play
pause that kind of stuff if you have
some other album art there are some
other ongoing notifications all that
kind of stuff can be controlled through
some swipes in the gestures so from what
we got to play with it it was pretty
smooth nothing really hung up it seemed
like retail mode is working just fine
but if you're gonna check out a watch
like this you're gonna check out the
functionality and how it connects to
your phone so that's what we saw so it's
a little bit unclear at this point
whether the watch is using all of your
phone sensors or if it has a bunch of
sensors of its own it has no physical
buttons but what
have as a nine axis gyroscope
accelerometer basically to be able to
tell when you raise it and that's when
it'll brighten itself and you'll be able
to see all your notifications and the UI
but other than that they made it sound
like the pedometer and all the other
sensors will come from the sensors in
your phone which is getting away at
Bluetooth so really coming in at 229
this is less than a pebble steel it has
a lot more functionality if I was pebble
right now I'd be very concerned about
this kind of stuff and Android wear is
getting a lot more in a spotlight with
watches like this the LGG watch and of
course the Moto 360 which I do want to
get hands-on time with but there you go
guys that's your hands-on with the LG G
watch here in San Francisco at Google
i/o 2014 thank you for watching I'll
talk to you guys the next one peace